astronomie est connue écologie victoire
de l'écologie dans les cévennes dans
cette région continue après les loups à
être réintroduit des animaux sauvages
par exemple des bisons d'europe des
chevaux mongols
reportage sur place de jean pellieux et
claude barnier a rescapé des temps
préhistoriques ce qu'ils ont mal à 8 ans
il pèse près d'une tonne
c'est l'un des plus beaux animaux de la
réserve de margeride au nord de la
lozère
les bisons vivent est encore ici il y a
deux mille ans
en france le dernier a disparu des
vosges à l'époque de charlemagne en
cette fin du xxème siècle en europe
il y avait plus qu un seul troupeau de
bisons en pologne les à propos que des
épidémies menacées de disparition à
titre préventif
les français en ont fait venir un pli
groupe ici en lozère on pouvait
effectivement accueillir les bisons dans
de bonnes conditions car il y avait tous
les éléments naturels pour les
accueillir c'est à dire déjà l'élément
principal qui est la forêt le bison
d'europe est un animal forestier 40% de
son alimentation est constitué des
corses
ensuite un climat qui lui convient c'est
à dire que nous sommes en moyenne
montagne
et puis bien sûr l'espace qui est
primordial pour l'espace les hommes ont
été généreux 450 hectares ainsi les
bisons peuvent vivre entre prairies et
sous-bois ans kelly liberté pour
permettre aux touristes de les observer
la réserve et des calèches à leur
disposition visite confortable donc mais
sans garantie totale de résultats bien
sûr on ne peut pas vous garantir que
vous verrez du bidon d'arrêt grandes
réserves
tout simplement parce qu'ici les animaux
sont libres totalement libres libres de
faire ce qu'ils veulent d'aller où ils
veulent et bien sûr libre de se montrer
ou de ne pas se montrer nous attendent
pas tout à fait normal grâce aux
naissances le nombre de bison a doublé
depuis l'ouverture
la greffe a donc pris en lozère avec un
nouveau troupeau de bisons qui a acquis
son autonomie
une assurance pour sauver l'espèce
même objectif sauver l'espèce pour un
autre programme toujours dans les
cévennes mais 100 km au sud un paysage
tout différent lalande du causse méjean
l'espèce animale ici c'est un cheval
mongol le cheval de przewalski du nom du
savant qu'il a étudié l'ancêtre de cet
animal figure sur les parois des grottes
de lascaux de petite taille
crinière foncé c'est le dernier cheval
au monde qui n'a jamais aidé domestiqué
il ya sept ans on a prélevé une dizaine
de ces animaux dans des eaux ils sont 29
ici aujourd'hui
actuellement nous avons deux groupes
familiaux un groupe principal qu'on
aperçoit dans derrière et puis un autre
groupe un peu plus un peu plus petit et
il ya également un groupe des talons
célibataire c'est pareil pour les jeunes
du monde c'est comme ça que se forme
d'autres groupes tout en évitant les
problèmes de consanguinité
on prévoit d'être possible d'envoyer
quelques groupes de ses chevaux dans les
steppes de mongolie leur pays d'origine
les cévennes
en attendant leur servent d'escale avant
le retour vers la liberté